what's up guys bang-bang lunch money
time
well while she's trying to get rich
restless just trying to get a lunch
money right I'm here with the beautiful
and annoyed plain Tamara Nova he went as
good his chair this morning I can't sit
next to somebody in a Canadian tuxedo no
problem don't forget we're sponsored by
black fine get money get paid deposit
crypto or digital dollars and you can
earn up to eight point six percent APY
it's like an interest-bearing deposit
account on steroids
eight point six percent APY that's
literally better than the stock market
normally does in a year there's risk go
to your own research head on over black
Viacom's last lunch money let them know
we sent you and that Polina loves me are
you ready to get started yeah what's
going on for small biz nearly a quarter
of small businesses are considering
closing permanently due to kovat we need
your energy up right now let's go let's
get the party started
it's fine we can talk about the
seventy-five percent that aren't going
out of business twenty five percent are
going out of business
twenty five percent may be considering
it but they're not all gonna go out of
business remember weeks ago i said
twenty percent of small businesses not
coming back
pretty accurate what's gonna happen to
the PPP money so PPP money's gonna run
out that's the big problem here is PvP
so unemployment for example which is a
fiscal policy the unemployment beefing
up of the unemployment insurance at six
hundred ollars a week that ends July
31st is game over so but if you are
given a PPP loan well that money's just
gonna run out so you basically you had a
certain amount of time to use it I think
and there's not more to go get so the
whole thing comes down to like at some
point they can only either one run off
the cliff right which it looks like it's
gonna happen right now or what they may
do is introduce more stimulus my guess
is that they're gonna introduce more
stimulus like that there's no way that
they can just say okay like we're good
now
after only three trillion dollars
remember what I said five
trillions gonna be the number five
trillion or mores what they're gonna
have to do in order to weather this form
we talked to a small business owner
yesterday he owns a restaurant next door
hey Zeus hey Zeus he owns a Spanish
restaurant and he said that basically
they're not letting him open up his
restaurant fully so only at 50% capacity
but he's also allowed to open outside
and put some tables out there so he's
hoping the other 50% he can make well
what he said which was very interesting
is he said he called the mayor's office
and said hey I need the permits that you
are making me get or I'm gonna have to
shut place down
he said they actually jumped in to kind
of help him out and got on the permits
quickly so he can add some outdoor
seating and do certain things but uh I
mean that that's the situation right
he's like look I'm gonna have to shut
this thing down
he's there every single day he said he's
the chef he's a waiter he cleans he does
everything it's his life right he enjoys
doing it and if they don't help get
these places open they're gonna shut
down so I'm long small business
entrepreneurs let's get them all back
working these people want to make a
living
let's get it going what's going on with
job cuts all right so your immolated
your best friend Kevin O'Leary
I mean kept her cool has some stuff to
say he said that many businesses are
using the pandemic as a cloak to cut
jobs and that they're just using the
pandemic as an excuse to cut jobs
they're already gonna cut I mean look
but this is true of anything right
there's a lot of businesses that are
gonna shut down that were just bad
businesses right they're gonna blend it
on the coronavirus there's plenty of
people are gonna lose their job that
they might have already were kind of on
the path to losing their job that
happens all the time I think it's less
important about like why some of this is
happening and it's much more to
understand the what of what's happening
because if we see again 15 plus percent
unemployment if we see 20 percent of
small businesses go out of business and
learning 10 percent of jobs in America
disappear records if 20 percent of small
businesses go away they make up 50
percent of jobs in America that means 10
percent of jobs would disappear that
means that there is 10 percent of the
jobs that previously existed there's
nothing to go back to there yeah right
and so it's just like you know what we
end up seeing is a
IMF International Monetary Fund
previously thought that we were going to
see three percent drop in GDP this year
globally and 5.9 percent drop in in the
US yeah they just yet I think today or
yesterday revised those they now think
that we're gonna see 4.8% drop globally
and an eight percent drop in GDP in 2020
here in the US and so it essentially
says it's like it's worse than
previously thought
right and also they think the road to
recovery is going to be slower than
originally thought so you just get a
dislocation stock market exploding
savings rate up personal income rate up
all that stuff that's great when Federal
Reserve's printing money and just
injecting it all over the economy the
problem though is at some point reality
takes over 40 plus million people lost
their jobs
20 percent of small businesses probably
aren't coming back you literally got
governments that are reeling you've got
hospitals that are reeling financially
but this is not a good situation
and so we got to open up the economies
be smart intelligent safe all that and
let's get people back to work that's how
you solve economic problems is you get
the economy back going something going
let's go bring it back bring it back
bring it back so you know how I like
shopping online yeah we know
ok the doorman knows dude it's like a
package a day keeps the keeps papa way
that's that's the saying our house good
anything to keep you away okay so
t.j.maxx
you look at AT&T though on how you got
to talk about fashion right now like I'm
more fashionable than you so TJ Maxx is
not allowing people like me to shop
online why they do not believe that
ecommerce and online shopping is the
answer LOL they're okay they have a tiny
online shopping operation that's only 2%
of sales so they took it to another
extreme and fully shut down its websites
during the quran virus log downs
making online ordering impossible but
now since they kind of started opening
up right ninety ninety eight percent of
its sales are in store but now
sailes so just so we're clear let's just
cut to the chase ready uh t.j.maxx
obviously has an idiot running the
business no no they took a 900 million
dollar loss last quarter so how smart
are they okay just so we're super clear
about that yeah this is real
but the sales at the reopened stores are
actually higher than they were a year
ago in the flood dead cow bounce coming
back dead cat bounce I called it I told
you guys I told you was gonna happen
heads up demand everyone's gonna run
back economic data is gonna spike wait
till about six to eight weeks after this
you're already seeing it in states like
Texas for the economic data looked
fantastic the first 10 days after
reopening the economy it's already
dropping okay in China in China
there was the massive drop in economic
data they reopen things there was an
explosion people were like oh my god
it's coming back bigger and better than
it ever was now it's settled back down
20% below pre-pandemic levels same
things gonna happen here 900 million
dollars max shopper they like
discovering things they do not like
shopping online let me tell you this why
would you ever double down on your on
your online sales when it's only 2
percent of your business
well I don't know if you can make it 2
percent and grow to 10 percent that
would be a 5x of your online sales that
seems pretty good especially you're
losing 900 million dollars a quarter
this is like blockbuster being like why
would we ever want to mail DVDs yo
Blockbuster what's up
now you just change your name to TJ Maxx
I bet you there's an executive at
t.j.maxx that used to work at
Blockbuster like literally it's just the
same playbook Oh innovation let's run
away from that that's scary
it's like come on if you don't have
online business now in 2020 you're
either an idiot or you're literally
trying to go bankrupt TG fax it's
actually doing pretty well there was a
profile and I think last year what do
you mean they lost 900 million dollars
last quarter one of the rare examples of
retail stores that were doing well
because they had so much foot track all
these women who want a good deal I'm
telling
you know your mom Shops at t.j.maxx she
does and guess what they still lost nine
hundred million dollars last quarter
it's just there's no way to run a retail
business in 2020 with no online presence
it's not sustainable it's dumb stupid I
could be the CEO of t.j.maxx you know
I've literally just run I'd uh have a
campaign and so I should be CEO of
t.j.maxx you know like someone make an
online business that's it that's all I'm
not gonna change anything other than I'm
gonna add a website we could buy [ __ ]
online do you think your mom would buy
stuff online from teachers if my mom
knew how to use the Internet yes she
would my mom still is trying to figure
out why when she gets on her cell phone
sometimes she can't hear and we have to
explain to her could you have to raise
the volume no yes
go ahead let's go what's going on with
American Airlines baby hey they're
thinking of raising 3.5 billion dollars
in new financing they already tried to
raise what was it 1.5 no no basically
remember they gotta pay go out oh we did
American get a bill yeah they all got
bailouts so don't forget that when the
government gave billions of dollars like
50 billion dollars to the airline
industry two-thirds of the money was a
grant so the American taxpayers everyone
watching this and us we gave American
Airlines money for nothing
wasn't debt was it equity wheeler just
gave it to him said here's two thirds of
the money here you go now all of a
sudden they're realizing it's not enough
it wasn't enough so they got to go out
3.5 billion dollars in new financing
newsflash what did I say in the
beginning I love right now we're hitting
about 90 days plus into this thing now
yeah I can start taking my victory last
I said the government shouldn't bail
them out the government should forced
them to go the equity and debt markets
and raise capital so they could sure
about of course I'm doing it now but the
fact that they're doing it now and they
didn't do it eight weeks ago is because
they were waiting on the government to
bail them out the government was the
idiot in the room that sounds like some
cat poop to me literally they got the
best terms in the world from the
government what private investor would
have given a company billions of dollars
I said two-thirds of it yeah it's a
grant so a non-profit question if our
tax
when we pay taxes if they were
transparent we actually saw where the
money was going would there be like
literally like this amount goes to bail
out the airlines well it's not so much
taxes I say taxpayer money just being
like it's the people's money of the
government right it's not necessarily
like your tax or just any money to give
Federal Reserve's balance sheet is
expanded by 75% in 2020 it's if they've
literally added three trillion dollars
to the Federal Reserve balance sheet if
they do another round of stimulus and
it's over a trillion dollars which is
likely to happen that means they'll have
a hundred percent expansion in a matter
of months
Wow right and so that money again what
we know is here's the worst part we know
where the money went from this thing
goes it's all written down on paper
super transparent you go google it
online we know that what airlines got
what all this stuff what we don't know
is why aren't people freaking out about
this it's because people don't
understand how money works
remember the system is built on 50% of
people not understanding how money works
American Airlines bail out
now they go to the financing markets why
do we bail them out they still got to go
well they should just one anyways we
bailed them out because the short-term
pain to alleviate the short-term pain
right but now they're feeling the
long-term pain and now they got to go to
the private markets know if they're
raising three point five billion dollars
now in equity and debt markets what they
should have done who should have said go
get eight point five billion dollars
they wouldn't be able to yes they would
not only I would have given it to them
at the right terms the government's on
the business of making sure business
gets good terms it's called the market
rate if you need capital and you go to
the market and investors are only
willing to pay a certain price then
that's the market but exactly you're
approving the point of they didn't like
the term so what they do they went to
the government and got better terms why
is the government giving better terms to
companies and private investors maybe I
should turn to the government capital I
have some progeny has capital going one
way they just take your money they don't
ever give you any except if you're an
airline yeah except for if you're an
airline and every once in a while they
were stimulus good h-1b one visas
all right so Trump signed this executive
order that would suspend all foreign
work visas so you cannot come on the
h-1b visa anymore so now the UK is
trying to war the text
that normally would come to the u.s. to
the UK by saying hey we got this global
talent visa if you'd like to if you've
been affected by the u.s. decision what
do you think is gonna the long terms
affect the long-term effects of this
here's what I'm gonna say I don't care
what your politics are if you look at
business there's a saying that a lot of
people in Silicon Valley use which is
the people you hire is the company you
build hire good people you got a shot at
building a good company hire shitty
people and you got a job a pretty good
opportunity to build a shitty company
the people you hire is the business you
build that is no different for a nation
the people that you have inside of your
nation or likely to be the type of
country that you built so if you want to
incentivize the best the brightest all
of the kind of innovative creative
intelligent people to come to your
country your life that have a shot at
being innovative creative intelligent
successful etc if you instead make it
super hard and add a lot of friction and
sometimes even in certain cases not
allow them to come and and them it will
be much harder to build an intelligent
creative innovative country this is not
rocket science go ahead and hit on with
the stats of what immigrants have done
in the United States well before I hit
him with the stats guys think about this
if we didn't have like an a visa program
and a green lottery green card lottery
well 1/2 of lunch money wouldn't be here
today it might be a better show because
of it whoops okay hit him with the stats
on the immigrants he's wrong here's a
stat on the immigrants more than half of
the privately held US companies founded
over the past two decades with a
valuation of at least one billion
dollars were started by at least one
immigrant entrepreneur examples uber we
work SpaceX think about that for a
second 50% of businesses that are worth
over a billion dollars in the United
States 50-plus percent of them were
started by an immigrant what are we
doing I don't care what you believe
politically but is
is absolutely nuts to draw a line on an
on an imaginary line in a map and say if
you're smart we don't want you to come
into our side of the line I'm curious
why he chose to do this like it's not
really this is a legal way to come to
the United States is it because the
claim that immigrants are taking jobs I
have no clue if you want to make changes
to the way immigration works fine cool
figure out a better way to do it I'm all
for it if you think there's a better way
you can figure out how to do it you can
get into proof the democratic process
all that stuff
knock yourself out if you can make the
process a little more streamlined not be
great
do whatever you want to do but the whole
idea that we're just going to issue
executive orders without going through
the democratic process and it is going
to prevent people from coming to the
United States who can help us it is like
literally the equivalent in an over
generalize way would be like sitting
inside of a house on fire and saying
we're not gonna let the firefighters
come we're gonna solve this ourselves
we've got a bucket we've got some water
maybe we got a blanket around here
somewhere we'll figure it out I mean to
me it's just when you meet somebody from
another country who's really smart who
wants to come to the United States and
start a business
know what no they have such a crazy
motivation that you rarely find in a
country where you know people are given
all these freedoms so it's just kind of
sad my whole thing is we should have
ruthless competition if you're American
and you need to have regulation prevent
you from or help you be successful
because you can't compete in the arena
on your ideas and your hard work it's a
kid shots I'm gonna say it but [ __ ] you
that's what I'm gonna say right because
guess what the best people they want to
compete against the best in the world
bring the best here
let's go toe to toe let's see who wins
and sometimes
people born with the ovarian lottery in
the United States they'll be successful
other times gonna be born elsewhere who
cares
just let the smartest people compete in
a free market and let's go let's go
build a great country that will have
lots of successful companies this is not
rocket science this is a first on the
show but I agree with every work good
job stick shift our IP Segway rest in
peace Segway guys Segway the most hyped
invention since the Macintosh ends
production it was supposed to be bigger
than the PC some dubbed it the most
hyped product since the Apple Mac but
today it is a sad day in less than 20
years after its first Segway release the
brand will retire its last Segway Dean
came in come on bro what are you doing
listen Segway they were right they were
no Segway was right and they screwed it
up we now have motorized scooters
there's bird there's lime there's all of
these scooters 69 years old lives in
Rockville Centre New York what is going
on Segway was right but somehow they
didn't win okay I don't understand how
they didn't win how is it possible well
I don't know maybe because literally the
Segway looks stupid okay it doesn't work
that well and paul blart mall cop
completely ruined their branding I think
the birds and the whatever the goose is
whatever the leaders on the line yes
birds and lime look just this goofy and
it's harder to balance on them yet
people would get getting on no why
literally Segway compared to burger line
Segway looks like the Boomer version it
does
you got that wear a helmet you ever see
people on a bird in the line they're
flying around they got their air pods in
they are well the products up to in
terms of its just its ways of use bird
or line than it would be for Segway it's
all about the business model right if I
got to buy a couple thousand dollar
Segway versus I can go outside and spend
two dollars to ride down the street and
there's just one sitting around randomly
outside that's like all of those things
distribution business model all that
stuff matters the Segway was right but
they lost I'm very athletic
I cannot balance on a frickin bird to
save my life I it's dangerous it goes
very fast by the time I like kind of and
also if you're a woman you probably have
like a bag of some sort it's just a
whole mess and he's over here yeah
athletic speed kills
and by the way planet just like planet
jizz license there's no athleticism yeah
she one time I'll take it as a quick
story before we let you go one time one
of the first dates we ever went on was
the New York public city library and and
as we were walking through it all of a
sudden about halfway through Polina
literally just went and grabbed her
hamstring and started screaming I
thought she got shot I literally thought
she got shot in the library and she like
throws her bag towards me I grabbed it
and she starts hobbling around I was
like what just happened because I think
I pulled my hamstring in the library
what a nerd you get hurt in the library
really steep stairs first that is the
most nerd thing I've ever heard you
pulled a hamstring he carried my bag
which I appreciate yeah all right that's
it for lunch money guys well while she's
trying to get rich for us I was just
trying to get a lunch money right Polina
is gonna keep annoying me I'll survive
alright guys don't be careful on the
birds and the lines you nice to your
friends nice to and t.j.maxx get a
[ __ ] website bang bang hope you guys
enjoyed this episode of lunch money as
much as we did don't forget lunch monies
now sponsored by block five so go check
them out there's a link in the
description that you can click on
I'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of Blackfyre
than you are of me block-wise my second
favorite thing in the world behind
Polina
they've got three products they can give
you a US dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell cryptocurrencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but eight point six percent
it's pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks that block by subscribe to our
channel like the video annoy playing in
the comment and we'll see you guys
tomorrow and be kind to your friends